we have to ask
the very basic question of what
is life i actually don't think that's
the right question to ask
it took me a long time to get there
right so cross it out yeah
you cross it off your list it's wrong
um no no no i mean i think it has an
answer but i think the
part of the problem is um you know most
of the places in science where we get
really stuck is because we don't know
what questions to ask
um and so you can't answer a question if
you're asking the wrong question
um and i think uh the way i think about
it
is obviously i'm interested in what life
is so i'm being a little cheeky when i
say that's the wrong question to ask
that's exactly like
the question that's like the core of my
existence but um
but i think the way of framing that is
what is it
about our universe that allows features
that we associate life
to be there um and so really what i
guess when i'm asking that question what
i'm after is an explanatory framework
for what life is
right and so most people they try to go
in and define life and they say well
life is
uh say a self-reproducing chemical
system capable of darwinian evolution
that's a very popular definition for
life
um or life is something that metabolizes
and eats
that is not how i think about life what
i think about life is there are
principles and laws that govern our
universe
that we don't understand yet that have
something to do with
how information interacts with the
physical world
i don't know exactly what i mean even
when i say that because we don't know
these rules
um but it's a little bit like um i like
to
use analogies you'll give me time to be
like a little long-winded for a second
even in as i um but um but sort of like
if you look at the history of physics
for example
this is like so we are in the period of
the development
of thought on our planet where we don't
understand what we are yet right um
there was a period of thought
in the history of our planet where we
didn't understand what gravity was
um and we didn't understand for example
that planets in the heavens
you know were actually planets or that
they operated by the same laws that we
did
um and so there has been this sort of
progression
of getting a deeper understanding of
explaining basic phenomena like
i'm not gonna drop the cup i'll drop the
water bottle there you go okay that fell
right but why did that fall
this is why i'm a theory it's not an
experiment i could have gone wrong in so
many ways
i know i could have especially if i did
the confidence smash anyway
um so um so if you think you take this
view that there's sort of some missing
principles i associate them
uh to information and what what the sort
of feeling there is there's some missing
explanatory framework
for how our universe works and if we
understood that physics
it would explain what we are it might
also explain a lot of other features we
don't associate to life
um and so it's a little like people
accept the fact that gravity is a
universal phenomena
but when we want to study gravity we
study things like large scale
you know galactic structures or black
holes or planets
if we want to understand information and
how it operates in the physical world we
study intelligent systems or living
systems
because they are the manifestation of
that physics and the fact that we can't
see that clearly yet
or we don't have that explanatory
framework i think is just because we
haven't been thinking about the problem
deeply enough but
i feel like if you're explaining
something you're deriving it from some
more fundamental property and of course
um i have to say i'm wearing my
my physicist hat so i have a huge bias
of liking
simple elegant explanations of the
universe that
um you know really are compelling but i
think
um one of the things that i've sort of
maybe in some ways rejected my training
as a physicist is that most of the
elegant explanations that we have so far
don't include us
in the universe and i can't help but
think there's something really special
about what we are and there have to be
some deep principles at play there
um and so so that's sort of
my perspective on it now when you ask me
what life is i have some ideas of what i
think it is
but i think that we haven't gotten there
yet because we haven't
been able to see that structure and it's
and just go back to the gravity example
it's a little like
you know in ancient times they didn't
know i was talking about stars and
heavens and things
they didn't know those were um you know
governed by the same principles as that
starting to experiment here's where i
was going with it once you realize
like newton did that you know heavenly
emotions and earthly emotions are
governed by the same principles and you
unify terrestrial and celestial motion
you get these more
powerful ideas um and i i think where
life is is somehow unifying these
abstract ideas of computation and
information
with the physical world with matter and
realizing that
there's some explanatory framework
that's not physics
and it's not computation but it's
something
that's deeper answering the question of
what is life requires
deeply understanding something about the
universe as
information processing universe is
computation
something about like would uh once you
come up with an answer to what is life
will the words information and
computation be in the paragraph
no i don't think so oh damn it okay i
know it doesn't help does it i know i
i hate actually i hate this about what i
do because it's so hard to communicate
right with words
like when you have words that are um
ideas that have historically described
one thing and you're trying to describe
something people haven't seen yet
right and the words just don't fit so
what uh what's wrong is it too ambiguous
the word information
we could switch to binary if you want
yeah no i don't think it's binary either
i think information is just loaded i use
it so the other way i might talk about
it is the physics of causation
but i think that's worse because
causation is even more loaded word than
information causation is fundamental you
think i do
yeah and um in some sense i think the
physics so this is the really radical
part
some sense like when i really think
about it sort of most deeply
uh what i think life is is actually the
physics of existence what gets to exist
and why
and you know for simple elementary
particles that's not very complicated
because the interactions are simple but
for things like
um you know you and me and human
civilizations
you know what comes next in the universe
is really dependent on what came before
and there's a huge space of
possibilities of things that can exist
and when i say
information and causation what i mean is
why is it that
cups evolved in the universe and not
some other object that could deliver
water
and not spill it um i don't know what
you would call it
uh maybe it wouldn't be a cup but um but
it's a huge it
it's um you know you know people talk
about the space of things that could
exist as being actually infinitely large
right i don't know if i believe in
infinity
um but i do think that there is
something very interesting
about the problem of
what exists in its relationship to life
so do you think this
the set of things that could exist this
finite
it's very large but like if we were to
think about the physics of existence
like how how many shapes of mugs can
there be like
is uh in the initial programming i
should go to the
math department for that but so that's
not a topology question i just mean
maybe another way to ask is what do you
think is fundamental
to the universe and what is emergent so
if existence
i was supposed to think of that as
somehow fundamental you think
so there's a couple problems in physics
that i think this is related to one is
why does mathematics work at describing
reality so well
um and then there is this problem of we
don't understand
why the laws of physics are the way they
are or why certain things get to exist
or
what put in place the initial condition
of our universe right there's all of
these sort of really deep
and big problems and they they all um
indirectly are related i think to the
same kind of thing that
um you know our physics is really good
if you specify the initial condition
at specifying a certain sequence of
events but it doesn't deal
with the fact that other things could
have happened which is kind of an
informational property like a counter
factual property
um and it's not good at explaining
uh you know this conversation right now
it's just it
there are certain things that are
outside the explanatory reach of current
physics and um
i think they require looking at it from
a completely different direction
um and so i don't want to have to
fine-tune the initial condition of the
universe
to specify precisely all the information
in this conversation i think that's a
ridiculous assertion
but that's sort of like how people want
to frame it when they talk about
um you know the standard model is
sufficient
if we had computing power to basically
explain all life in our existence
an interesting thing you said is the way
we think about information computation
is by observing
a particular kind of systems on earth
that exhibit something we think of as
intelligence
but that's that's like looking at i
guess the tip of an iceberg and we
should be really looking at the
fundamentals of like
the iceberg like like like what makes
water and ice and and and the chemistry
that
from which intelligence emerges
essentially
we can't just couple the information
from the physics and i think that's what
we've gotten really good at doing
especially with um sort of the modern
age where you know software is so
abstracted
um from hardware
but the entire process of biological
evolution has basically been built
like been building layers of increasing
abstraction
and so it's really hard to see that
physics in us but it's
much clearer to see it in molecules yeah
but i guess i'm
trying to figure out what what do you
think are the best tools to look at it
what do you think an open mind
is that a tool what's the physics of an
open mind
i think if we saw that we'll solve
everything i'm saying an open mind
because i think the biggest
stumbling block um to
understanding sort of the things i've
been trying to articulate or
and when i talk also with colleagues
that are thinking deeply about these
same issues
is none of it is inconsistent with what
we know it's just such a radically
different perception
perception of the way we understand
things now that it's hard for people to
get there
and in some ways you have to almost
forget what you've learned in order to
learn something new right so i feel like
most of my career
trying to understand the problem of life
has been
variously forgetting and then relearning
things that i
learned in physics and and i think you
have to
you have to have a capacity to learn
things
but then accept that things that you
were you learned might not be true
um or or might need refinement or
reframing
and the best way i can say that is just
like with a physics education there are
just certain things you're told in
undergrad that are like facts about the
world and
your physics professors never tell you
that those facts actually emerge from a
human mind
right so we're taught to think about say
the laws of physics for example
as this like autonomous thing that
exists outside of our universe and tells
our universe how it works
yeah um but the laws of physics were
invented by human minds to describe
things that are regularities in our
everyday experience
right they don't exist autonomous to the
universe right so it's like turtles on
top of turtles but
eventually gets the human mind and then
you have to explain
the human mind with the turtles yes so
you have to
yeah it comes from humans this
understanding the simplification of the
universe these models
you